you know what happens if we don't stay
on that path of knowing what our rights
are knowing what we believe and why we
believe it they will keep a coming they
will keep a coming with the lies they
will keep a coming with the lockdowns
and they will keep coming with with far
worse things uh Jordan Peterson actually
talked about some of those far worse
things with Rita panahi on Sky News
Australia do you think what we did
during covert could usher in our version
of a social credit system oh yes
definitely yeah yeah and that is highly
probable and that it will be accepted by
many people because again
yearning for safety no they won't notice
even yeah you can't believe how much
people don't know these things when I
went to the UK I talked to some people
from the House of Lords this is within
the last six months the most astute of
the people sitting in the House of Lords
had only become aware of the woke
movement in the last 18 months oh yes
you just can't believe how much
this is not on people's radar not
someone like you can't believe that at
all because it's on your radar all the
time that's not you live in a world
that's on The Cutting Edge of this sort
of thing it's like people have no idea
it's like well why not have a digital
passport
I mean you know how convenient like fair
enough and you can understand that
wouldn't it be nice if we could pay for
everything with our phones it's like
wouldn't it be nice if the central
government who's woke oriented and makes
carbon dioxide remediation the priority
knows exactly what you spend on
everything so they can Target you tax
wise with Precision it's like oh you can
think about that it's like yeah
yeah you sure didn't and oh yes it's
highly probable it'll be in a miracle if
we
if we escape from that you can see these
signs of this everywhere you know when
you go through airports now there's a
lot of automated barriers you show your
passports like
well these are automated barriers what
if you can't go through them
well that's the situation for many
people in China it's like what are you
going to do you're going to argue with
the machine like you just cannot imagine
how screwed you are there isn't it's way
worse than anything Kafka I ever
imagined because at least with Kafka
there was bureaucrats
faceless though they may have been they
were at least Still Human once the
machines can lock you out
you are in such trouble and we're
speeding towards that with uh
with an immense lack of
of care you see why it's important to be
awake I would say if you watch this show
you're probably
an edge case on the front end of this as
he described to Rita meaning that you
you are aware of some of this stuff you
probably didn't lose your mind over the
couple years even though we were all
given these horrific choices to make
about going to work or being vaccinated
or all these things but we saw some of
the stuff we were willing to question
some of the things all of those things
and a certain amount of people aren't
and then a certain amount of people as
Jordan's laying out will one day after
the digital passports are in and all of
the stuff they'll get to the airport
they'll scan their thing and the Machine
will tell them no you can't get on that
plane
you liked this video or you did this or
that or were freeze in your bank account
so all of these tests have been running
throughout the West it just is guys but
now Elon is exposing it and that should
give you some serious freaking oomph
behind your desire to keep going